[Music]
so good evening everyone this is Grand
Master with you I'm so happy to be with
you all and the people in the chat
especially everyone who's there and B
Simon is here now and he's not pissed
but I'm about to piss him off by
changing the subject for the third time
no no Ben's not ready for that are you
ready for that Ben seriously do don't do
it I will not do it okay I'm just
kidding okay fine that's okay that works
that works okay we don't change it off
bit lines off bit lines because you know
in my in my free time when I when I'm
not teaching chess or I'm not working
out I'm pissing off P Simon that's one
of my favorite activities but not
tonight okay we're going to skip that
and uh with with off bit lines so uh you
know Gary some s you know some walk me
through tell me one of the offbeat
gambers people play these days and it's
very hot and then we kind of try to
smash them or maybe just show that they
are actually playable we can discuss
them uh Gambit Evans
Gambit let's start with the Evans Gambit
huh that's actually among the sound
ones let me okay that's Evan's Gambit
let me uh open my file guys for a
second or
here
perfect Evans
Gambit so I have to tell you something
funny guys so Evans Gambit is named
after
who Larry you see everyone makes that
blunder I just wanted to catch that one
it's not L after Larry Evans it's name
after Captain events from from late
1700s and it's a British guy all
actually it's a captain Evans not not
Larry Evans it's not named after him
it's actually a very old system and you
have to think about it because Stein's
played that so and Larry EV wasn't
wasn't of so yeah it's it's an old yeah
it's
uh a steamer captain and correspond
somebody says steamer captain and
correspondence player well in those days
they had to play correspondence just
probably because every move would take
like months to get from place to Place
probably in the 1800s so before uh we
take the we take the Gambit so number
one is that some people say just decline
let's go back it is playable but white
can at the very least gets a normal
Italian with already winning a Tempo
with a move B4 it's not an advantage but
uh we take the
Gambit no his name people say if his
first name was Captain no his first name
was not a captain he was he was a
steamer Captain as they said yeah Bishop
takes B before we take it we take the
pawn C3 and now and now after C3 there
are a number of choices here there was
Bishop
A5 not there are actually there are few
only and Bishop E7 these are the two
possible moves to
play and Gary are you familiar with the
events Gambit I'm not that's okay though
don't slow down for me okay keeping up
okay good so um so which one do you play
do you play this at all with black
pieces
no no s okay anyone here plays
it so some this
say oh somebody's referencing to the
movie The
Jackal so first of just don't play this
because after D4 white is
better and the best move Bishop E7 is
possible and a lot of people follow this
system and Bishop E2 and uh Kasparov
beat Anand with this move Queen D4 but
now it we know it's playable but a lot
of people also play this system just
take the pawn and then this is a very
playable interesting position another
move is Bishop E2
uh and they play
D6 and queen A4 check C6 and this is
also
playable but uh I find a little bit a
tad uncomfortable playing it as as black
just because of the activity you have to
know a lot of only I would say only
moves a lot of good moves from black
side all very concrete moves and the
kind of moves that you cannot just sit
there and just reason finding finding it
so not my cup of cake cup of tea cup of
cake cup of tea
so I go Bishop
A5 and they go they have here three
moves Castle D4 and
uh and the castle D4 4 and uh Queen B3
so I think D4 is the main move because
playing the Gambit is Spirit play
D4 Ben Simon what do you think do you
want to play D4 or Castle or queen B3
first castle Ben castles but that's one
of the opinions let just look just
that's just look your your opinion
man that's that's the reference that's
the reference to the big Labowski he's
not watched the mve and I'm picking on
him until he watches the movie you have
not watched the movie so that's just
look your opinion it remains that so
Sarah what do you want Queen B3 Castle
D4 I mean I'd like to play D4 it's good
H they're all not so great but uh that's
start with D4 let's play The Spirit of
the Gambit so
D4 uh and we have to play D6 very
important move um it's easy to go down
this rapit hole that it's playable but
it's uh
boy very practically difficult to play
as white as black so playable yes do I
recommend it
no I I like the6
better now they
go there's detex E5 DX E5 is nothing we
just take on E5 uh you can check that
with the engine quite simple the moves
that that are more challenging is Queen
B3 and
now here's a big question what do you
play against this move you have this is
the moment you have to remember these
are the I I I suggest to my students if
any any want to learn an opening take
images of of the moves that are
important and why do you have to play
those moves and once you do that you can
place the P these pieces of moments
these these pictures next to each other
and then you have a frame of reference
of the whole thing how it
works so you have to defend on F7 Pawn
right you only have one way to do it
because if I go Queen
E7 then he goes D5 and then it goes
chick winning my Bishop so you have to
put the queen on
D7 and then comes the next moment when
they go D Tak E5 what do you have what
do we have to play I'm going to leave it
to you sir and the the people in the
audience just to find this very
important move for black it's a Tempo
winning move is a very important that's
the only move that doesn't lose and
actually gives black in my opinion a bit
of comfort and maybe slight Edge not not
Edge because top players playing it
regularly and the position is balance
but this is a very important
moment white has a very daunting
initiative
okay let everyone think about it a
little
bit
so
yeah somebody
said somebody said in the in the
audience online and that's Bishop B6
because this move I'm trying to win a
Tempo with this move and I'm getting my
Bishop out of it's it's like not that
beautifully placed on A5 so I'm getting
out of the way and I'm creating a threat
of going to the A5 Square after Bishop a
bishop
B6
White
so the Knight A5 is is a big threat
there so we we continue with
um white has a number of moves Knight
bd2 continuing with
development and Knight to um there's
also even A4 to play Bishop B5 and but
but this this is this is the move to the
point Knight Knight Knight to
D2 and we played Pawn T
pawn bishop A3
Knight
A5 a very important move here I give up
I give up the pal back give the pal the
pawn on E5 so Knight takes
E5 and after Knight takes
E5 we have a very strong move here cute
tactic Bishop takes F2 check now I
cannot take with the King because
there's king queen Tak D2 chick so must
go Queen D2 King
E2 and Knight Tak B3
and
uh funny enough that he can take back
because the queen cannot go anywhere and
the move Bishop takes F7 is to
Inc incriminating so I'm going to go
back with the bishop Knight takes Knight
takes Queen Bishop takes and as a result
of all of these things happened white
has some activity but now he's the one
down
Pawn because he played he played the G
with I mean okay he's a still down upon
but he's not down upon actually and only
has counter play only has compensation
and the position is uh considered uh
balanced well I would say balanced maybe
white has enough compensation for the
pawn uh practically it's just down the
pawn so yeah that's part of it and then
here uh I want to discuss this move
Queen B3
first
Queen
E7 D4 now I cannot go D6 because we
talked about if I go D6 there's D5 so
what can I do what should I do as black
when in
doubt whenn in doubt trust the four
golden rules get your develop get your
king to safety watch your material and
get the space and Center so space and
Center we cannot do much about it so we
have to develop and get your king to
safety Knight f
six D5 and now what do we do a beautiful
Cheapo a very beautiful
chipo
so do you see this
pain KN D4 very important move capture
capture castles castles don't even think
about capturing this guy Bishop G5
Knight D2 Rook E1 you get under attack
quite fast
so
quickly this
F3 Pawn takes pawn bishop A3
D6 Knight takes Pawn so here uh in terms
of material black is still up a pawn but
White Center is very strong look at
those pawns on D5 F E4 F3 so if white
gets to mobilize these pieces let's say
Play Bishop back to B2 Rook to E1 let's
just let just draw some
arrows King here F4 E5 I'm I'm under a
lot of pressure so I need to
take imminent action right away and that
is with what move this is a very
important move this is the equalizing
move for us and actually Victoria simite
or Chim I don't know how to pronounce
her name do you know who she is
Sarah she's a
Grandmaster she's married to Grandmaster
uh Peter hin
Nelson 252 F rating is her rating and
she's probably the tallest Grandmaster
in the
world she's probably 25 tall 2 m five 25
is like what
67 no it's more than that she's 67 tall
something like
that and she found this she found the
initial idea
just so uh what should would you as
black
so I have to break these pawns
uhhuh so I go Knight
H5 with this
idea
uh King to
uh King to H1
F5 Pawn Tak
F5 Bishop F5 G4 and this is what you
have to memorize here it's it's such a
such a complex tactic that you have to
memorize this position the best the
second best move by black is equal this
the first move wins for black and that's
in no one's uh paycheck because you have
kind of just have to know it and that's
the move B5 double
xclaim rejects the whole system
so let's explore this move if if if Bish
if Queen takes then we just take on
C3 if Bishop
takes then it's kind of gets very weird
A6 now again if he takes any of these
pieces they we take on C3 Queen takes
and we take on B5 these pawns are really
weak because they're not defending each
other and this is well protected and on
top of that I mean just these pawns are
going to start falling one after the
other and if the bishop moves let's say
to C4 then Rook Rook B8 and surprisingly
this this queen has nowhere to go to
keep defending this Knight which leaves
black white with the choice of taking
one of these pieces again which again
leaves white with bad Pawn structure and
if I go Knight takes B5 here's when it
gets very cute Bishop takes G4 check
sorry not check Bishop takes G4 and
because the Knight is deflected from
caring a square after they move F takes
G4 we have this beautiful Checkmate
Queen E4 check King G1 and Bishop B6
check and Y King is exposed to all kinds
of chicks and mate is
ensuing so um and if uh and nothing else
that's it
so wraps up the Evan's Gambit okay that
was number one what's what's number
number two on the
list do we want can we run a poll with
people what kind of Gambit they want to
see well the Danish yes we can do Danish
we pretty heavily adverti the elephant
in the thumbnail elephant okay do
elephant let's do elephant
yeah is
that oh sorry that's that's SK scandy
I'm just what am I
doing
all right let me just get my analysis
here are the elephant and the thumbnail
what are they are those gambits or what
no the thumbnail is just what's
advertising the video there's an
elephant in it because last week he
mentioned that the elephant hit would
beon
so there's Gambit called The Elephant
Gambit that's that's right
yeah okay so in the elephant Gambit uh
there are many ways to face
it and uh this is the one I suggest so
we're going to we're going to play eex
D5 and now um in most books they suggest
just to move Bishop D6 if they go E4
what do we do about E4 H let me ask
the queen2 queen E2 yes we go Queen
E2 I actually play this in a Simo in
Charleston South
Carolina play like D3 Knight Knight F6
it it's it's important D3
Knight Queen D5
and here's when I made a mistake
actually it's very important to know
that the best move is uh Knight B2 D2
the engine likes Knight Knight C3 at
first but Knight B D2 is the strongest
move Knight C6 D takes E4 Queen whatever
let's say queen H5 and then just Queen
B5 you want to trade the queen your OPP
healthy Pawn nothing NADA here nothing
happens
here even Simon can win this
position
so but there is this move Bishop D6
which Alpha zero actually
likes
so because it's a positional sacrifice
and if you don't know what you're doing
then you can run into some trouble but
you have to know the next move for white
here I play some Knight C3 Bishop B5
nonsense in a in a in a simultaneous
exhib I played in South Carolina this
year in Charleston again actually that's
in what was that
2020 oh it was 2023 actually this past
year the other one I mentioned that I
played earlier was
2022 so here
uh
D4 um
E4
and now where do we put the Knight so
there is a debate whether this is score
or that but I think just Knight E5 and
you're
good my suggestion is Knight
E5 and after Knight
F6 Bishop B5
check I mean whatever they
do and I see a lot of uh correspondence
game in this position but white has won
one so I'm just going to I think this is
a correspondence game and I I I've seen
this name before so in correspondence
game nowadays they use a lot of engine
work so pretty much if the engines prove
that this position is winning by force
then it wins by force so castles he
played
this oh this actually old game not not
the best way of playing it but anyways
castle
castle A6 you can just go back B
B2 Knight D5 C4 and you have a two be uh
two beautiful Bishops um this is not
working because of C5 Knight E2 this and
then the bishop has to move and I win
this Pawn by force and if the Knight
goes back to F6 still I go C5 Bishop E7
Knight C3 castles um Bishop E3 and I
have a lovely position with B4 this
queen comes here rook's coming to the
center and in start just pushing on the
queen side with ease because black has
no counter to play on the queen king
side the point is that uh this Knight
has nowhere to go because this bishop CS
everything and this Knight cannot jump
to E5 because the pawn is still D4 the
moment I go D5 I'm ready to push further
so if the Knight comes to E5 it's not a
big deal and white has a pleasant
Advantage
here oh hey Bill how are you I I'm just
happy to see my good friend and
uh uh who live in the same city Durham
North Carolina is's saying hi here
welcome to the show Bill okay uh um so
um
yeah that's elephant Gambit in a
nutshell
for Ben Simon thank you you're welcome
you're buying dinner tonight
no ice cream maybe maybe ice cream okay
maybe ice
cream so elephant Gambit only worth an
ice cream guys just don't don't play it
it's very unworthy
opening
so what
next I Gambit Gambit which opening col
Gambit Colorado Gambit it's really bad
so what I don't even know I'm sorry
excuse my lack of knowledge but what is
it called so how do you play it I think
it's
like
so any anyone in the audience want any
sort of Gambit do you know any Gambit
that you may want to learn about
yeah for the audience you know where the
word Gambit comes from I mean people
speak English they know but I'm just
because we have people from other
countries so I'm asking do you know what
Gambit means where it comes from the
origin no
no good what it means yes we know what
it means but the origin of the word some
somebody says anti engal engal Eng gland
Gambit uh wanan Gambit but that's a
sound one okay actually
that's okay I I can I can I can dismiss
that right away that's okay but but uh
so the word
Gambit comes from
um from off the word offering because
you didn't play play Gambit usually
offer a piece or Pawn or something like
that but it's a form of offering that
was in um that was uh that you would
make it let me just see exactly is
you're making an offering to the king or
something like
that I used to know
that so Gambit
means it's an
Italian
um I think someone in the chat is
talking about yes colored Gambit SS Okay
so
you you make the opening
move and then uh so someone's a bit a
pached and no they don't know they just
talk about Gambit tripping the legs
that's what the that's what it says
tripping the leg is the Italian
translation for the Guma G
so okay so someone wants jum Gambit I
don't know which one is that jum Gambit
very bad what is it a chest think it's
like
God how does that I don't know this
these things okay let's do that come on
let's do
it so jum Gambit I don't know what this
gosh anti someone says anti and gland
Gambit I don't know I I've heard of a
vanan Gambit or wagan Gambit that's
that's in French defense that's what
this is wagan Gambit I think this is uh
okay I think this is this is called
vagan Gambit and actually this is this
is a sound opening but uh what's the
Jerome gamb bit e
E5 Bishop C Bish c
b and somebody has actually played King
E7
here somebody has play King E7 I mean
that is that is a first
so okay you want me to refute this
opening
gives minus five so I I was wondering if
if it's if it's possible enough
plausible enough for me to imagine that
for example Alpha zero or uh or stuff
which can beat me in this point but I
think minus five that means that they
cannot what's that probably got
it if I I don't I don't know how if I
can if I can be I mean okay this is this
is the thing right you just have to make
a couple of Moves In you're up a piece
only
okay no but it's not easy actually how
do you win this you people have to know
this one because people can get a bit
cocky here and move make moves like this
and then sudden there's this check and
then there's is compensation so the best
to do is to just give it away give it
give one piece away doesn't doesn't
matter and then get the king to safety
then you want to play D5 King B7
sorry and then you're good you're up a
piece
all right actually that was not a bad
question we need to know this one if you
don't know this one yeah no I mean
surprisingly it's not that easy I mean
okay you can also play Queen H4 check G3
oh this is also possible this is also
simple what am I talking about F takes
E5 Queen takes E5 and that's just
completely winning s a piece it's a
disposable opening it only works one
time for those who want to
know and if they go D4 just guys don't
forget to take on F5 because uh don't
blunder surely okay that's Jerome Gambit
done how about the Danish Danish okay
that's a sound that's a semi sound
opening so E4 E5 Knight sorry D4 oh now
here I play D5 I don't take it the
PA don't don't don't just don't go all
the way with the G with I mean this is
playable I think this this is I I I know
this is playable and there have been
analysis in it and I I'm sure that moves
like D5 just equalizes I if you want to
do I knew this since I know this since I
was like maybe nine and that's like 30
years
ago and uh this is just enough for it
for equality I
think uh this queen
D2 I remember we analyze this two
equality Rook d8 Knight F3 and G8 and we
consider this now the engine says 0.1
for white on a low depth but I'm sure
it's a Balan
position so yeah so but I nowaday
suggest that question please go ahead
why you put
thaten Bop ah that position okay let me
let me let me go go to that moment I saw
that yeah because this is hanging now oh
yeah there you go okay I missed that so
want to win something for it yep yep I
understand absolutely so I suggest D5 of
course of course so of course D5 Pawn
takes Pawn uh and then Queen takes D5 C
takes D4 Knight C6 Knight F3 Bishop G4
Knight C3 Bishop B4 do all the
pinnings and when I teach CH kids love
it when I say pin it and win it and kids
never miss a pin that's fantastic Bishop
E2 and let's
see there is D4 Knight F6 C4 C5 Knight
F3 ah that that wonan Gambit I can look
at that one too that's that's a whole
kind of warm to open chield b or uh
whatever is your ID is there but uh that
I can just address it quickly so this
one and then here uh I'm sure you've
seen it uh and um capture capture Queen
C4 and uh Queen B3 must be played take
take and then everything has been
diffused and just a very balanced equal
you want to Castle play A6 Castle make
sure nothing's happen here Castle Rook
here Knight F5 this is a very sound very
solid position Problem free so you have
had some experience with this one
there's some some smile some devilish
smile on your
face the first chess club I ever went to
the instructor his favorite thing in the
world was the
and I was able to be
him
well he surely needed to up his game
probably he needed to up his
game so
um so Queen C4 was copyrighted by
capablanca okay we'll have that one in
mind then s put it in the in the in the
uh what was that tag
lines put it in the tags copyrighted by
C Lanka
so uh let's look at Wan gamb with this
one that people are talking about now I
know what they're talking about
now this is a sound this is a sound
opening you know what's what's sad about
this opening if white wants to draw they
can go Knight C2 D5 C takes D5 and then
you have to go Queen D5 and they can
just trade and play E4 and that's just
very dry drowish position I actually
played someone and he played Knight C2
against me to make a draw and I was like
mad and I played Bishop C5 and I'm just
just was worse this this thing is
dying okay it should be plugged in I
think the
uh no I
got this power Bo God this 2024 is just
snake bit for anything I'm involved with
El
okay don't don't blame it on 2024 oh no
it is there we go now it's
all
right all right so let's say white wants
to play for a wing Knight here D5
captures Bishop C5 one thing everybody
has to learn what happens if they go D6
if you go castle and this moveie is not
possible how
so it's very important in blit happens a
lot I played in Blitz I know it's wrong
it's it's probably even losing
but if they don't know people and people
don't know this and I actually end up
winning material I win the
game let's see if can somebody can find
it Bishop takes F2
well I don't think that that one
works no I don't think that one
works
looks lost yes people say looks lost but
it's not so the move is Knight Knight
Knight to
E4 attacking the F2 Pawn E3 and
then Bishop B4 check very important move
again now if I go Knight D2 I lose right
away Queen takes D here Knight takes A8
hook d8 and that's just dead
lost Knight D2 is coming here
how do we win
this o lovely and the King comes up here
and I we pin
it nice tactic beautiful tactic huh
so
um Rook d8 wins but okay you should not
play like that Knight C3 is the right
move to
play now Knight takes Knight Pawn takes
Bishop takes Bishop
D2 and here you need some very strong
move to
play and that is um Bishop
A1 here you need to find a very good
move no it's not a very good move it's a
it's a move Knight C6 Queen
B2 Bishop F5 Queen takes B7 and Rook to
d8 or B8 either one
wins just why doesn't have any
development these two guys are out of
the
party and if I go let's say Bishop E2
um wow we cannot do this because he
castles and he has compensation but the
way we can play is that we can play this
move to prevent Castle what what what
doesn't prevent Castle
yes because of Bishop
H3 the bishop cannot move to he has to
keep defending this guy and that's just
uh winning so must go Knight C7 and then
the engine plays like this don't do that
unless you analyze this all the way
through the engine says this position
after crazy Bishop H3 and then you just
play this take on H should take on the
one you have you're
better okay if you if you analyze this
position if you feel like doing that
with the engine and play some Blitz
Games Against the engine on chest then
you're good to do what what's been I'm
sorry
just was very happy I figured out how to
turn the keyboard back
on guys give him hands B come on this is
going to help me help you more trust me
oh perfect guys the days the night's
just getting better and better by the
second
so so um Bishop just just pick up just
just in my opion just pick up the
pawn but if you want to study that
position after Bishop after Bishop E2
Queen G6 will be my
guest that is uh that wraps that one up
what else ah okay what else that okay
that is if they do that but uh for the
most part they go Knight C3 you go
Castle okay obviously I cannot go E4 I
lose to Knight G4
four uh so they go here
G3 and uh then you have a number of
moves you can play Queen B6 I like this
move
better it's very
much down my alley I I really like these
kind of
positions so this Pawn sacrifice is is
nothing for for for us Knight f and
light scores are so weak because of this
G3 move light scores are so weak so like
let's say if I go Queen
E2 this is this
this like this is Swiss
cheese so Castle is a must Knight
df6 Knight
D2 the engine is not so happy but I'm
happy I play play say black close my
eyes the attack is
rolling H3 Knight H6 yeah I wish I could
play some of the sacrifices but it's
it's an
another Knight Knight H6 Knight
B3 Bishop D6 Knight
B5 Knight F7 Bishop
D2 Queen E7 and we're down the pawn but
we have a counter
play Knight takes Knight takes Bishop
Knight takes back oh Knight takes back
is wrong sorry my bad I T back I get
pinned I get pinned here so must take
with the queen oh my God okay I win this
Pawn okay A3 and then Queen takes
D5 you know what for a Gambit it's a
hell of an effort to just go and win the
pawn back and then Rook C1 and then you
now you say oh white has two Bishops
white chances are SL slightly better
well I don't like that game Gambit it's
a lot of work for just say oh okay you
the best play Black can equalize
eventually eventually so what's the
point of giving the pawn for the Gambit
not an attack nothing just you know end
up with a slightly worse End Game
Pass
so but if but the thing is when you play
the sideline which is not the queen B6
you are
um
so someone says the engine when I when I
just blunder the rook and I and I'm
still
winning well still winning by the engine
or you think you're winning that's a
very important that's a very important
thing to distinguish that you have to
make
here someone says am I covering gambits
today I think that was the whole thing
with the offbeat line was so yes I'm
covering
gambits so um finally uh so that's one
of the lines but another line that they
play is that is very common is that they
play E3 here and here we have to go
E4 Bishop E2 Queen E7 or Knight D7
doesn't M doesn't
matter or Rook E8 do they all did the
same thing castles Bishop F5
A3 Knight
D7 B4 and Bishop D6 and this Pawn
actually works for us H in but this is
where you have to have a good knowledge
of Pawn structures it happens a lot with
the reverse colors in Queen's gamb would
accept
it that at some point your opponent's
Pawn is on C5 and you play E4 C takes D4
E5 and then you have an attack and
that's where it is but in Queen's gamb
accepted you have an initiative and here
you have compensation because you're
down Temple so white play is like
this and uh black play is
uh get the pieces to the game and then
uh now I want to have some sort of a
this
this it's okay so Vienna Gambit which
one is a Vienna Gambit is
it F4 not C3 F4 is the Vienna Gambit or
Vienna game what's that I don't know
yanish Gambit is good if white is not
booked up uh actually yish Gambit is a
sound Gambit okay now for a wrap up this
is the this is a playable position black
has comp compensation how does he have
the compensation because the engine says
so I played it in practice because of
the threats I can have as I said along
this diagonal and then provoking this
moment with G3 it's playable but
honestly I don't have fun playing this
in a classical game or I don't have fun
playing it period because because it's
just so much work again to prove that
you're you're okay whereas you can just
play something much more solid and just
be okay
again I don't know when I was 25 I I was
probably was happy to play it because I
wanted to win a game now I just want to
get a position that I can understand
better and play it I think it's a matter
of energy here but now people have
mentioned that I want to mention few few
sound Gambit that are playable so one of
the gambits that are
playable is yanish
Gambit what's it y yanish yanish Gambit
with
J it's written j a n
e
Yani e i s C H I think it's a it's a
it's a is it a j a e n i s c
yes I think it's a it's a it's a Finnish
name where is it or no maybe maybe it's
not maybe it's a it's a Polish name I
don't know so so that is a very okay I
just want to mention that somebody might
watch this one he's a student of mine
and he's always plays the Lan game with
this is very on sound one this this this
is dead shman too
also
they like it yeah let them like it
because this is dead I can tell you this
is dead Knight C3 Queen G6 F3 xcl that's
that's just game
over this is over e takes F3 Queen F3
the point is they cannot take this Pawn
because you trapped you tra the you
trapped the
queen so other and otherwise Bishop D3
comes with the tempo and Castle because
they cannot play Bishop F5 you can take
on
B7 so that's this is
dead
so um yanish is this uh yanish or shman
Bishop B5 and F5 and this is playable
I've SP I spent a ton of time on this
opening and uh this this is a sound
opening practically as white I suggest
if you don't want to be
so uh consumed by this opening and spent
so much time studying it just play the
D3 line follow Carana there and uh he's
is he's been successful with it quite a
bit there have been wins and losses but
most of the time they end up in a good
position out of the opening you want
more
work and Knight C3 is your line to go
and I think Domingo has played against
whom did you play against Knight
C3 KN C3 F
E4 Domingo is against uh
naroditsky I cannot find the
game but Domingos against niski was the
game gets a slightly better end game for
white and that's uh yeah that's my to go
line I
think it doesn't pop up here but I know
I've seen this
before so somebody's somebody's sharing
some history for with us I'm going to
read it out loud so um Carl Fred F
yanish Russian
call Andre
andreich
yanish was a Finnish and Russian so I
was right about the Finnish part chess
player and theorist in the 1840s he was
among the top players in the world
yanish Finnish
Russian sounds
cold sounds very
cold all right this isn't sound sound
sound Gambit this is a sound Gambit so I
spent a lot of time and uh given all the
games played in the correspondence
database it's it's it
stands it it works
okay what's next are we done or we going
or what's the what's the plan the
Stafford you mentioned the staff
Stafford
okay this no he he's gonna argue with
the engine
running about the gamb no we didn't talk
about the buest
Gambit what's that I
play well that one that one is only that
that one is only dead if you know a lot
lot of a lot of theory so that's
playable that's in practice it's
playable because you have to know a like
insane amount of uh moves I don't know
Theory but my level my opponent so I
don't want them
I so um Stafford yes
Eric uh is it Stafford Stafford is this
huh I actually have a file on Stafford
campit I have a I have a file on
Stafford
Gambit because I I had a student he was
losing he lost like three times and he's
1400 and I prepped a file for him
so let's see what I suggested for a
I have it
saved somewhere I'm
sure okay I cannot find it so I'm trying
to play from the memory so we take on C6
I remember that we take on C6 D takes
C6 and
uh and they go DT C6 we go
D3 and and what's going around is that
everybody plays after D3 Bishop C5 and
they're hoping that this is what there
not 200,000 videos on this one that
Bishop G5 and then Knight takes E5 four
and is that isn't that the one Bishop
takes d8 and then they show this
Checkmate it's going all around isn't
that the most watched video of the 2023
or something it was on chess.com inan
would yes so anyways but um we're
not we we're noww after Bishop
C5 so uh my suggestion is that and I
know uh Eric analyzed this line with H3
Bishop takes F2 and then Knight takes E4
not not my thing I mean it is probably
objectively okay for white I remember I
looked at this position and white must
be winning but uh your king is still
weak and is like in the middle of the
board and uh you need to still
come find solution to some practical
problems my suggestion is just play
Bishop
E2 Bishop B2 Knight G Knight G4 and I
know uh they're still counting on you
castling which they can play H5 against
but we just take and if they go Queen to
H4 yeah I have it
now all
right the engine says the engine says
you can go Queen F3 Bishop takes G4
Queen G3 and it forces the trade because
now if you go Queen H5 you go H3 Bishop
D1 and Knight C3 but even if you don't
want that kind of problem here's here's
the
solution I take and I play G3 and I
don't care in the world what is it if if
if a down the pawn end game with a
better Center for me is all you can get
will be my
guest done there's no threat nothing
right up a
pawn so
Stafford
trashed what's
that what what is very
bold the the claim no it's not a it's
not a bold claim because guess I
even no but I mean but you don't have to
play that move you can play H5 right
here and if it n Go H5 here now you have
time to play C3 and you could D4 now and
once to close that Bishop all threats
are
gone
the thing is somebody has to sit and
spend like maybe half an hour just make
sure he knows all the lines know ideas
not half an hour maybe 10
minutes so someone says being up a upon
means nothing to me
well that speaks for your chest not not
for your not for the
physan there was a time that I could win
upper PA easily this this is more than
just up a
pawn
well H5 is preparing to move Knight G4
because we just know Knight G4 you can
just take it now and queen H4 you can
just force the trade
so if you want to get good at it I would
say um you should uh you should just
check the lines uh people play this
against the computer but that's not the
right way because the engines will avoid
all these risky tricks because that's
not the best moves the carding to the
engine say they low on the evaluation so
playing with the engine doesn't help him
here so people say then there are lines
with like H5 c39 G4 D4 this somebody
says some line let me see what it is let
me
see so this this
this G3
and queen F6 F3 H4
F G4 HG Bishop
E3
um Rook H2 Rook
G1 I you can do also King D2 here just
simply well there's one thing if you
want to win against the staford gamb but
in the first place you have to be a good
chess player more than more than lines
you have to play good chess I mean you
cannot win any game without making good
moves and at some point you cannot just
memor memorize everything so you have to
be able to see the board and make make
good
decisions
okay are we
good any other thing maybe we can cover
more uh gambits next week maybe we can
look at the more sound gambits next week
on Thursday on Thursday yes
yeah do
that Noble double grub Coca-Cola Gambit
what is
that it's G4
g54 G4
G
datab okay this is
wow that is
a wow that I'm learning something
tonight that haven't had in 35 years
playing chess not 35 years no what I'm
talking 30 30 31 years
yeah wow that goes over my
head all right well thank you for
joining me uh sorry for the momentary
aberration uh and
uh uh we have we got all the lights
back thanks thank you Ben and I'm I'm so
proud of you your discovery which is the
light which was the what was the light
key fantastic and very productive night
thanks for for joining us again thanks
for the audience online see you around
and uh I'll see everyone tomorrow at 6:
p.m all right thank
[Music]
you